let's get more reaction from Russian and
Muhammad valleys our correspondent in
Moscow interesting noises coming out of
Washington and it's interesting to hear
that there may be positive noises coming
out of Moscow
well so that's uh uh by the looks of it
the two sides have been talking about
the need for negotiations for a long
time the two sides have been showing
their conviction that there can be no
solution to this conflict except through
the negotiating table this is only a
repetition of what has been said over
and over again but here the
understanding of Biden's statements here
Moscow seemed to be
uh that there is a precondition by
Washington that Russia should show its
Readiness to withdraw from Ukraine and
that is unacceptable here in Moscow
Dimitri Pesco of the Kremlin spokesman
said that's not acceptable Russia
considers those territories now Russian
territories and one of the problems of
any negotiations with Washington is that
Washington doesn't want to recognize
that these territories are now Russian
so we see that the two sides are still
very far apart and he said the Special
Operation will continue until Russia
asserts its rights and and secures what
it is uh what it considers its goals and
and and plans for this conflict
so Russia hasn't budged in terms of its
instance from the first day and the
today is not not a big difference but he
said that President Putin is ready for
negotiations and he thinks that only
peaceful a peaceful solution is the way
forward and early negotiation can be the
way forward but that doesn't mean the
end of what Russia is do what Russia is
doing now in Ukraine
thanks for the update